breeding some podcast Vil it's Monday
July 29th get your [ __ ] [ __ ]
together after year is over and you're
still sitting there [ __ ] waiting for
your cousin to get you he's gonna give
me a job
go [ __ ] you and your cousin the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by CBD lying calm listen to me no
more liquor store [ __ ] CBDs you go
into a [ __ ] record store they got
seed these CBDs and want to expect you
buying what do you think you're [ __ ]
buy you're buying [ __ ] actually you're
buying listen uncle Joey's here to tell
you the way to go is CBD line you're
lucky you [ __ ] got me and I
found CBD line you know why because they
make CBD products from start to
[ __ ] finish CBD Lyons got you
covered whether you want to smoke in the
vape and the cards rejoin the shatter
whether you want to eat a gummy bear or
do the tincture your uncle Joey lives on
the tank just do me a favor go to CBD
line calm right now
no pressure and check out their third
party lab results for yourself then get
back to me understand me I wouldn't [ __ ]
them put a CBD honey that I didn't
believe in on a percent go to CBD line
calm right now pressing Church CH you
are CH and get 20% off a check out the
church what's happened now is also
brought to you by listen go look at the
mirror go look again that's what they
look like they look like the front of
the monster's house you understand me
there's bushes there's three different
colors and then you cry I'm gonna
untended I can't find nobody yet I'll
SWAT left the [ __ ] life the more I
see in this damn you gotta [ __ ] take
care you're nuts you gotta keep him nice
in the shade you see I'm in commercial
with the woman's raises how they stand
in front of a plant the mage got a heart
like a little stick and then the sinew
waits at the woman shapes that means you
too you filthy [ __ ] nut why have you
boss smelling like a [ __ ] elephants
[ __ ]
uncle Joey's here to tell you to be a
gentleman you gotta clean the bumper
before she touch sucks the [ __ ]
tailpipe really no [ __ ] listen my
friends over at manscape created the
only tool you need to shave your nutsack
and the area around the [ __ ]
pogo sticks it's called a lot more port
2.0 for a [ __ ] reason they threw away
21.0 and they upgrade the trimmer
so it's skin-safe technology you
understand me listen they got a thing
called the perfect package it's a little
pouch you'll be [ __ ] covered for life
it's got everything in there your little
[ __ ] they look like a [ __ ] you have
Apocalypto bending down and [ __ ] like
[ __ ] it's Apocalypto day it must be
the second Monday in January but listen
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] right now the family
of the church the church family gets
another 20% off your first order when
you use promo code Church CH you are CH
at manscape calm and if you order the
perfect package don't also throw in a
free travel bag when you use code Church
CH you are CH trim those [ __ ] nuts
that's manscape calm use promo code
church for 20% off your first order and
keep your balls [ __ ] clean kick this
[ __ ] mealy Monday morning
[ __ ] Whitney Cummings here's the
deal with the way [ __ ] boss okay
I've been following wedding fees yeah I
love weddings because well okay let's
take it back to the my favorite wedding
of all time is the Godfather yeah that's
a wedding your father you dance or your
friends tons of food you invite singer
to sing whatever the [ __ ] kids that's a
wedding but that's not gonna happen no
more yeah in this country so what are
you gonna do I don't know what was the
fat black chick from the view they got
married
the first one Oh Shepherd no one before
they got married Elbert Oprah lookin
[ __ ] got married pigeons every
ball the black people had addressed in
white he was flunking them he was [ __ ]
the janitor you know the whole time that
was a different one there was one before
that did that so the more money you
spend on your wedding see you kissing no
hey star jones scarlet joy
spent eight million dollars lawyer right
yes like she spent a million dollars on
a wedding any China prayer you can see
John Mambo didn't give a [ __ ] your
relatives from with their shitty
speeches and then it's a lot everybody
had address online they released a
hundred pigeons those ones I give me
evil and glory in the black dude from
the San Antonio Spurs got married on a
ranch
they shot grenade what are you trying to
prove yeah yeah you know what you got
three friends you all would yeah that
would be heartbroken didn't go your mom
your grandmother yeah you know I thought
I was you you from the nation's capital
I would get mad at the nation's capital
really the White House on the flowers
the trees no no you know tribe once I
got my little Wednesday
my reasoning for this because I don't
want to have to have my friends or all
comics I don't want them to have to
travel there one weekend off don't don't
make nobody travel yeah you don't want
to do it to be what we do we travel too
much I want to do it so commerce you
just go home it's a matter of fact [ __ ]
comics you got three girl free welcome
yeah yeah Chelsea you got another one
yeah a girl from high school yeah your
parents your grandparents this guy these
[ __ ] parents nobody needs to roam not
yeah everyone's dead no I don't want to
take a picture preparing me for the fact
that you're not coming to my wedding
no no feels like an elaborate really
want to peek the pictures from your
wedding in People magazine them tell me
the truth if they pay money I would do
it if they gave mine to cover the spread
I'm mercenary like what was that what
did I read a dude and they gave a
million dollars that she divorced a dude
lost his NBA career the little [ __ ]
white that like arrow Chris yes
Humphries yeah yeah I'll [ __ ] four
million bucks I'll do anything I'll do
literally anything like she married him
but somebody pay for the wedding off the
books they had the first crack at though
yeah you get the rights to the photos
that famous but if if they pay money for
photos I'd get we give him away for free
on Instagram why not to get money for
but they did the wedding for that reason
the reality show also some films for the
show they needed a finale you know I
looked at it the first time I got
married it was great but where was it
Boulder Oh gorgeous I got married in
Boulder where gorillas at a hotel huh
real nice hotel by should talk with the
whole thing but the problem was my
gorilla buddies New Jersey came and it
was the day that colorado played
Nebraska Colorado rule number one take
notes don't get married during football
season if you want people to go okay
that that is actually [ __ ] great
advice that rule no more don't get mad
don't some well no one's given me that
were married during the Yankee Red Sox
weekend no bad ideas people gonna come
to your wedding and they're your
thoughts yeah you look beautiful and
then you gonna do what my friends did is
there a bar you over there is there a TV
no get from my gorilla buddy did coked
up out of his mind in front of my
in-laws took the [ __ ] bellman game a
yardstick made him go to [ __ ] Home
Depot in an extension cord and he went
upstairs read through the room brought
the TV down to the [ __ ] table at the
wedding an accident that's a meme and my
buddies watched the brown Colorado with
half the wedding and she's dancing you
know daddy's little girl nobody gave a
[ __ ] I think is a [ __ ] about Maddie's
little girl this girl has 13 13 you
gotta cover by three that's all I'm
worried about Saturday so you [ __ ] if
Ohio State's plan to do come on anybody
know any of those [ __ ] you done
what about Sunday's that's NFL that's
how I felt what time is that why you did
all day all day time was wasted no
everyone's [ __ ] wasted and angry and
I remember more women get beat up on
Sunday that's after the other fellas
they walk in the front of the TV you
don't want to get married he bet
Pittsburgh
get my ass kicked Amano I don't you
don't want that so okay so what months
do I have available to get married June
December well April May and June okay in
the DC area right I don't think I don't
have any there's nothing left for me and
[ __ ] DC because I don't want all my
friends stuff to go there yeah we'll do
it okay that was one of the first places
I did stand up with Sportsman's Lodge
there used to be a Friday at Saturday
and it was outside on a patio so you
something still that you'd have to time
your jokes in between cars traffic by so
you'd have to get your punchline on the
red light Santa Barbara gorgeous oh we
raced a little bit to me I still don't
got to pay for a plane ticket be out
driving you can drive home that man who
would come home they got a [ __ ]
restaurant next to the you got a caterer
from the Italian restaurant that's why
I'm gonna make the Best Western Hotel
it's the best Italian restaurant time to
give you a lasagna with a meatball in
the middle Oh
spaghetti with the ink that was squid
squid ink in it what the hell dude
forget tomato Santa Barbara people like
Ojai people really like but it caught on
fire I might have to move our whole
wedding cuz it caught on all right then
we go Orange County that's not a bad
idea
La Jolla everyone Orange County is a
Lloyd o earth we could do spots
that's what maybe La Jolla and we can
have a show that night and comics all
the attics that need to go [ __ ] get
on stage no it's your wedding don't come
here if you want to come and go [ __ ]
your mother
I know go [ __ ] your mother okay I'm not
a big wedding person I'm either I'm just
a special day I wouldn't want to come up
to you at 7:00 and go I gotta go I've
got a six-year-old I gotta go I feel
like it's gonna be like a roast where
everyone gets to get up and like a party
no why not why not or do during the day
so people can bring their kids do what I
did with my wife which one the second
one which was here did ya the second one
I did here I went to whooshes a little
chapel oh right on Wilson Lybrand they
make it look like the st. Patrick's Eve
I don't even know your parents don't
even know don't think you're oh my god
she's in Italy yeah it'll be good walk
in you get
we went from there how many people yeah
maybe before I had a good little girl
who my wife went to see today she's 12
or 13 was a flower girl oh and we got
married down there and then we had the
reception at the Hollywood Bowl cuz my
wife worked at the Hollywood Bowl so
they gave the house is a special house
where the band's could sit in
oh sure people know that rain I had it
there
I got simplicity but strong me from
Langa's with the [ __ ] bread so
there's no [ __ ] I know Wolfgang Puck
no no that I got fried chicken from
rounds yes please
he's a certain rouse and Hollywood the
black dude makes the best the one on the
Rock and Roll Bounce game used to make
the best he would make a feat of fresh
hops and fish he would fry the fish and
I also went to help coach you need no
and God it came that with Cuban pork
chunks with white rice black beans and
mother hands so everybody had something
did your wife have any resistance to
this plan no zero
I'm a don't know Wednesday before
Thanksgiving oh that's smart as [ __ ] so
everybody could come marry that one and
at 7:00 I wanted yeah no one had to take
off I was home by 8 o'clock and number
one I don't want you dressed up and
please don't bring a gift your residence
is more important to me that's a stupid
gift and who officiated the [ __ ] guy
down there just so ever a friend of mine
came from Jersey and we went down in and
we all went to think I was clean then we
smoked the pot and we just Grogan showed
Eddie Bravo red band Felipe Ralphie see
I like that I just want same pressure in
my life but that was the main thing I
sent down on the emails no gifts mm-hmm
I don't like gifts make me uncomfortable
- I gotta pretend I like it's like makes
me feel like I'm forum ya know and then
they get that other thing with a Shh I
gotta buy you a glass at a [ __ ] mall
at the woollen hill with your name on
the corny with that what's that call
when you get res names remembered know
when you get read
registry rather you Whitney a yard a
couple thousand for a wedding no Whitney
wants I'm not that person at all that's
what I'm saying so you have to decide if
I want something I have it what you want
I can't what I'm you know I would hate
for you to have this big illustrious
million-dollar whenever but Natalie do
you find that you don't like the [ __ ]
yeah what never well you're saying
that's think I like him if I spend a
bunch of money on the wedding I'll stop
I have the word this is you know I just
think that it makes future resentments
I'm gonna rebuy it my wife no rooster to
feathers oh yeah let's plan it the magic
bag in Detroit no to make a twenty year
I like that place yeah me too that's it
oh me too I'm marrying her can we plan
it yeah no please me and Rogan complain
it no tell them that day he like come
over yeah Cafe 215 but I do I do
everything that day so I don't put
pressure on you that's the most possible
pressure jump down the fireman's pole
and get to my my renewal of my vows
[ __ ] crazy I just want to do it with
her have the baby there so she gets to
see it you know so she gets always
remember how much should download the
mom happen come on yeah 20 year
anniversary why not where we're gonna do
it I don't know I don't know the side
will burn that bridge you can do it my
house no I haven't even thought about me
now like I have we just disgusted this
year cuz I know we're together 20 years
that's wild it's next year oh gosh we'll
be married for ten huh
it's together for ten together for
towards that what is to what how do you
stay married that long what is the
secret I was married when I was young
and I hate it I thought it was a sucker
stain I thought that a woman the truth
you want to throw the cards on the table
if I married you witness cuz I knew you
were gonna cook and do laundry and I can
ask you to [ __ ] it mm-hmm I didn't know
what came with it what responsibilities
man what responsibilities came and then
I ended up homeless with no kid I lost
my kid and you realized what
50/50 yep I did start making money with
my time until I started asking her for
advice because we're [ __ ] so when we
asked who we asked for advice
alcohol yes that's true so what do they
want to pay you what that's insane a
little [ __ ] so you're like yeah but
it's NBC my agent he's allowed to talk
to me like that was that no I just mean
like yeah they're like why would you
ever let someone treat you like that cuz
they're an agent and we need like just
look dumb like my wife like if I [ __ ]
up my wife calls me spied it from
Goodfellas the guys like yeah you [ __ ]
up tryna go get an Ambu you don't like
so she's sane person's point of view so
ya know I wanna just what was the
question how do you stay married 20
years that's [ __ ] insane I give her
the respect she deserves I still do the
date nights
I don't do stupid things with my friends
like I you know guys who go on trips you
think about it you think ahead of time
and flight rebei what's the I see the
guy anyway I'm getting divorced or my
wife cheated on me well next time you go
play softball with the guy you're a
grown [ __ ] man yeah from zero to 20 to
do all the athletes yeah you suck dick
at it now you want to play flag football
when you're 40 your wife gave birth 10
years ago once you're married for 10
years the [ __ ] gets way better
remember the whistle oh yeah because no
more outside condoms no more [ __ ]
stress what are you in fact once you
start dating somebody you're with them
10 years the [ __ ] is tremendous look
about the butthole I don't my wife in
the ass that's disgusting so 20 years
the pussy's even better it's used to you
it's like a tempurpedic you know when
you first meet a girl you go down on me
you sniff that [ __ ] its nips tremendous
but it's got like outside all is you get
small like different Caillou's [ __ ] in
there but and the more you with her the
pH starts to address
Oh Joey and the [ __ ] gets tighter and
adjust it gets like it's like [ __ ]
it's like putting your hand in the
Hollywood Wall of Fame side wide
especially when they stay with the same
man from all those years I'm like a
cheap tequila but that when the when the
husband dies at pussy's tremendous and
she's fifty fifty two and she's out at
Dan Tana's debone steak given that hot
[ __ ] yeah you have non kidding me cuz
now that's the problem he's 51 you know
in the Cuban you call them a B or D em
pulse like that Midway LA there are some
midway point these Marriott the impulse
that [ __ ] is good they compete with
dirty year old really all those 50 year
olds that have been married from 1813
all sorts of miscellaneous know they had
a divorce and for four years and didn't
think they had it and then now they
started going to the gym and yoga get
the key 50-year old you know in
Hollywood uh-huh Jennifer Aniston's
about to push 50 Jennifer Lopez just
turned 50 as well so lambing slamming
and yes there's things that go on there
by fifties the new 20 she she doesn't
drink alcohol yeah yeah you start you
really do but care for self Authority
you start taking care of yourself you
understand that you can't do five shows
unless you're in great shape you cannot
go up on stage if I'm tired a lot of
people now that you know what sleep
today what did you get the better now I
rolled twice it was [ __ ] 97 degrees
I'm like why what I got up my d was
drenched by otherwise would dress yeah
no you get that old down everything
helps everything helps cuz we have to
actually do two hours a night an hour
show you standing yeah yeah you know
everything [ __ ] help this tour was
the first time I really was like oh [ __ ]
you got a like I this is the first tour
I've ever brought my own microphone
which I know is corny and everyone's
would make fun of me I never did it in
LA why cuz I kept getting sick yes and I
I was so embarrassed because
seen someone do you member they used to
be a guy that came around the comedy
store who brought a microphone onstage
with a speaker and everyone used to
clown him so hard I think it was more
like the open mic circuit you probably
never met him and I kept getting
bronchitis and I never had that before
and I don't know if it was cuz I was
flying or I was just trying to do too
much I also was doing clubs this round
and doing like six shows a weekend you
remember I was doing like 5 o'clock show
7:15 show 9:30 show so I should start
getting sick and so I brought my own
microphone cuz and a doctor pointed it
out he was just like do you share
microphones with 300 Road comics like I
have like a microphone on my throat that
says Bobby Lee's ball sweat on and of
course I was getting sick so I started
bringing my own microphone and that
actually really helped kind of Mike did
you get that's a good idea I don't
remember I was so embarrassed but I mean
my opener could use it it wasn't like a
thing but I just brought it with me in
my bag and put it up and I don't
remember the brand I can send it to you
it was great looks great I haven't
gotten sick since I'm very worried
that's one thing that worries me a lot
not having something going on the road
and you could smell the flu do I happen
to calm you all the time you see someone
like go home what you're gonna get
everybody sick one person's got strep
throat everyone's got [ __ ] strep
throat no but if I hadn't really really
talked about the keys I mean we
struggled the first six years make
anybody have a couple finding your
identity were you touring a lot at the
time yeah I had no respect whatsoever
birthdays Christmas you gotta have
ritual it's like it's you got to figure
out what and I think everyone with are
like women you have every woman value
something different I value stuff like
that I do I didn't have holidays growing
up birthdays weren't celebrated
Christmas was everyone was fighting so
now it means a lot to me and sometimes I
know it's stupid but like a real
birthday dinner just means a lot to me
yeah and it doesn't matter why let's
just do something [ __ ] special and it
save us two months of fighting you know
sometimes you just got to just do it
I've been here a long time there's no
comments come go but I also saw how
comics ended relationships
I saw I've seen a lot of relationships
end and I look at and no matter how much
amount of money
mmm-hmm the relationship ends usually a
relationship ends because of stress over
money others have always had money so
what was it that was missing its time
together I love going on the road I
really do I really do
but I have a six year old and like I was
gonna go to Miami Thanksgiving weekend
which I'm still going the Palm Beach
improv know what though Miami I also do
a theater may go let me just do the club
yes except do it great oh it's - oh it's
great
I was only without Wednesday see this is
what I do now about Wednesday sellout to
show yeah Thursday who gives a [ __ ] go
to Boston Market
well yeah that's our key and the Friday
is sad they do to a piece and I go you
know what is the change I'm gonna make
Wednesday worth it being away from my
daughter for Thanksgiving she gonna be
in both 8:30 so I'm taking at a clock or
a lot and I get to Miami at 6:00 out the
way south-southwest meant to measure the
[ __ ] over I got no I got for a fine
private I'm by myself today nice and I
got the other one I got the yes to the
law spritzer sold min spritzer mag with
the logos on the plane ticket back just
in case I want to come back because I'm
in New York Friday yeah and I'm like
really I'm gonna come all the way back
to do new podcast and yeah I don't maybe
I'll do Sunday in Miami wake up late
check-out late take like a 1 o'clock
flight to the city yeah get into New
York it for get something to eat sleep
and then Tuesday do all that Sirius
Radio yeah and then do Town Hall Friday
that's a yes that's a thought that's
what my thinking was all right thanks
for what I don't want to be gone that's
the holiday these little things I have
to do because I have a family are you in
your relationship kind of like I am a
little bit of a loner like just by
nature I think this part of the reason
I'm good at touring and stuff like I
don't get that lonely on the road I just
don't and I think sometimes when I'm
touring a lot and I come home I still
sort of feel like I'm alone in a hotel
and my do it'll be like hey what are you
doing I'm like like it takes me a second
to adjust I
I need a lot of alone time which is
maybe part of the reason I can be a
stand up you know so that is something
that I think we struggle with a lot I'm
an only child
okay so I like my like I hate when I
walk in the house and they both attack
that's right I'd like give me 10 min I
love my daughter I love them but if I go
to do kickboxing for an hour I get back
at 10:30 a man from not in the tent
early in the morning everybody's calling
well I was soon as I get in the car I'm
just hitting the phone hey what's up you
have an audition hey what's up we gonna
push the meeting back hey what's up so
when I walk in my gonna start sending an
email and they both jump me so Sunday's
they both go to church they leave it
[ __ ] 9:30 so I think the first flight
out not walking at 10:00 so I got from
10:00 to 1:00 by myself I am beat my
suitcase yeah I just need to be alone
I give Mary self an hour I go on youtube
and watch three videos yes even though I
have my wife and my daughter I love them
very much
my wife knows I need my [ __ ] and my wife
needs her [ __ ] yeah after weed you got
to need the same share at the same time
that's the key like next weekend am I
going that I gotta go gotta follow week
yeah I'm going out tonight so I go out
tonight Tuesday and then you haven't you
when you're in town do you got a deuce
shows every night no Tuesday Thursday
said Monday's her Wednesday's are this
how do you like that I saw I looked at
the I thought about two things I thought
about relationship mm-hmm I thought
about because we have big questions that
we don't answer I thought about the
whatever returns what do I get my going
out city managing marginal return turns
between you know not sleeping not waking
up with her Tuesday Thursday Saturday I
can handle because I could still wake up
with her mm-hmm take the camp be a part
there yeah you know years ago Led
Zeppelin won on tour for a year and a
half done and they come back and now
they played family for a year that it's
pretty tough to play family after you've
gone for you
it's like gonna war it's like they say
when people come back from war they have
to do a week in Germany - it's called
neutralization it's just all sudden
jarring do you take that's why I hate
when people go on coming I'm going to
Boston from Saturday to Sunday wait a
second when do you go back to work
Monday come back Saturday
yeah my mother's I don't give a [ __ ]
where your mother's cooking come back
Saturday because you're gonna need a
vacation from the vacation is it getting
off the plane at 8:00 and you got to be
at work at 9:00
yeah I'm just saving you aggravation
yeah time and parts of your life forget
the dinner yeah it's out it yeah it's
the same bit as you're gonna make Sunday
with Uncle Louie she gonna make Saturday
Saturday a four-year out yeah you're at
11 o'clock you drive up to four or five
it's empty
yeah and now Sunday you do your laundry
yeah you look at your mail I just I'm
slow in my [ __ ] like I'm just like I'm
meditative at home I like to light a
candle I like to brush my teeth I like
to I don't like rushing at home really
either and I don't like feeling rushed
and I don't like feeling pressure so
it's like that's what I've been
adjusting to being in a relationship and
also I don't like being on or feeling
like I have to deliver or perform or be
interesting so it's been a little bit of
an adjustment at home going from like
dating and like putting on my best self
and being like charming and funny and
telling great stories and then
cohabitating being like oh no I'm boring
like most of the time like I'm not super
fun to live with you know I wish people
really know like you like I wish people
who in there they think I'm out shopping
with [ __ ] Tiffany Haddish and Beverly
Hills jumping up and now yelling that
way there's not wheezing waiters ass and
that's not you know it surprises me when
like I appreciate when people reach out
to do things like you know it's like the
other day too short reached out to his
party Thursday have one in the afternoon
yeah I wish I'd go to downtown at one
o'clock smoke dope I still got to drive
back on the 101 at 4:00 and I got to be
home for dinner I gotta be home for
dinner I believe let me tell you the pet
peeves I had growing up that penis I had
growing up was going to Whitney's house
to call for
in the morning I haven't for very nice
dad was very nice mom was nice as
siblings were nice
Oh while I was sitting there waiting for
you I would hear Whitney hurry up and
you please give me the brush out of the
bathroom Jesus Christ who took a ship
this early isn't there a roll and people
running and people standing up evening
Terry and your mother eating the cereal
because she's got a missed a train in 15
minutes
when I saw as a kid I go I do not want
that no hectic my house in the morning I
was very sick I was said they say in
France and I say quoi
janessa quoi yeah my house you wake up
you got a cup of coffee
you go outside I sit I have my coffee in
the morning yeah
I said no phone no love no talking no
news local god only knows I know I want
negative no no no light of my water I
don't even know don't tell me I go
outside I got a little vitamin D I drink
my coffee have about twenty do two
buckets to get the [ __ ] rage going in
the puss again life tolerable and then
you [ __ ] open up social mean I go to
work promote right and I have the
notebook I write my whatever for the day
when I plan to do wow I'm feeling what I
thought about last night said do you
sleep like a [ __ ] yeah eight hours
Wow seven times you nap CBB or do you to
adjust it yes
huh it's really helped it the two
thousand five hundred milligrams I pop
at night oh [ __ ] oth no they're little
gel caps okay now before I go to bed so
sun's a hammock he comes out at eleven I
walk in from the Comedy Store eleven I
pop it I go and I do some stuff I look
at my notebook for the next day and by
11:45 I'm already feeling yeah yeah I go
let me watch the end this one's a
Hellmouth you know watch then then I'll
lay down and now I am a mole - YP I do
to you pee every hour on the hour every
hour at night oh my god in the middle of
the night for a while there was terrible
there's nights that I just
and then I went on strike I wouldn't
drink water after so yeah people like
you died my doctor told me you get that
heart attack [ __ ] you like a little
catheter
no no so now I just started doing the
CBD I liked cryotherapy oh yeah you got
in the thing yeah bio makes you sleep
also very good so - steam doesn't have
steam and steam steam and cryo do you do
before you go to bed or just any time
during the day I'm gonna do it today cuz
you burn like 2,000 calories when you do
it right oh wait cuz you're so your
body's working so hard to stay cold one
today I usually do the one how many
minutes does it go Trish two three if
someone died in one of those be [ __ ]
in Vegas I think some yeah because
they're doing drugs the night before
someone was found dead in a cryofreeze
in pagan yeah there's the thing that
there's a guy that I met when I first
started going to cryo and I just bumped
into about two months of own apartment
hey Allison oh my god ah I got a heart
condition they don't want me to go in I
think it's the best thing I do I try to
go to that three times a week yeah good
for inflammation and sure it's time for
you breathing focus is your flight to
fight response we'll see that I love I
love it it's just what is mental what is
perception so you have to go in clothes
I put music on and I focus on the
breathing yeah I made sure that's keep
your amygdala deactivate don't go in
there right from yoga class cuz your
underwear sweaty and then you're gonna
freeze freeze I made the mistake one day
and my [ __ ] to nuts became one I
could feel him I could feel the one that
was like I'm cold together don't they go
in your butt like oh my god your body it
was like a little head and I wanted to
the bathroom I looked at the fries look
like the businees head it was just a
little frozen [ __ ] put away oh yeah
that just becomes one I got great nuts I
really do but what is them what are what
is great nuts mean big big lot of meat
to put your mouth but say this but high
up like tight high and tight
like a punk unlike just symmetrical
yes symmetrical I mean it's like an
elephant ear put the [ __ ] show on the
picture my nuts is hidden from you - you
wanna see that one okay you know do we
have pictures of the album cover than my
CD yeah Oh something I called it where I
get my balls that's right
what is this an update it is this little
tip this is the best how recent is this
this has to be about seven eight years
okay so we need to know it well it's
probably the only difference is great
hands and a couple wrinkles like you ran
the Russia alive yeah I think if I put
the Russian app on my nutsack right now
that's what it would get like a couple
wrinkles and some [ __ ] gray hair the
best was for me I'm sitting at one I'm
like I really want to call this out on
something well what kind of picture can
I get the forces I want I was working
Madonna
what would Madonna can I tell you people
don't think about that one of the
hardest things I think about doing
stand-up is naming your special yes what
will Madonna do hmm what we're gonna do
so I took a picture although what the
Felicia's having I would take a picture
of her balls what the Felicia's like Oh
Felicia I got a hi first I think I did a
big favor she's like what is it shall we
[Laughter]
tell me that's not beautiful right it
actually is [ __ ] unbelievable set a
ball look at that it looks like Dolly
Parton's tits like it looks like a
beautiful body I'm gonna leave it to you
I want you to take him out in a second
put a string in between them and play
that game number the 70s cracker ball
would they would yeah it looks like at
how good Kim Kardashian's but how
somebody has not asked me to model my
bulbous I can I tell you something on me
I actually thought you were joking but I
do think you do have beautiful long and
beautiful bald a lucky you didn't see
him from the left-hand I got a beauty
mark on the left side like that that I
think I see it it's like they're
something what's the name is Lauren she
had that beauty
on the side of face it's on the left
side it also it looks like Mount
Rushmore like there's these beautiful it
looks like two red woods like a redwoods
of steel you can I tell you something
I'm not even joking I'd be the first to
clown on them they are very very well me
and my wife um their boss do you shave
them I shaved them yeah but you gotta
hold that when you shave here to hold
him out right my wife and [ __ ] close
my eyes and pray she does him yeah she
shaved your balls
sometimes she shaved my balls for me cuz
I you know you can well your mom do a
happy marriage
that's the key to a happy marriage you
gotta have them shave your balls you
shame everything sometimes I shave
everything just depending on the
occasion there's no shampoo my hair gets
long it's like I get split ends you can
use chain regular shampoo I don't want
to use use a different shampoo on your
ball you're using your hair I put
conditioner on my head I get soap
antifungal soap and I wash my helmet
okay well let's get back you have to a
lot of people a lot of guys don't know
that know a lot of guys don't do it they
don't know it and it's stinks it stinks
terribly you've got a shampoo the pubic
hair I put like well a Boston
conditioner oh but I still get this
little balsam I don't even think they
still [ __ ] I made that where do you
buy conditioner on that it's not like
popular you know Halle Berry's [ __ ]
this makes a [ __ ] ball thing so you
[ __ ] yeah that's good to know and then
you use a razor or electric razor for
manscape Oh dad it comes with them
detachment you to shave your nuts it's
just for nuts your nuts huh and then you
take it off and you shave around it
uh-huh it's the summertime it's you
don't want to have that [ __ ] oniony
smell on top of 56-year now I don't want
to smell scallops oh man dick no I Kelly
I like hairy air people don't know how
stinky their [ __ ] gets either
oh my [ __ ] horrid in between I call
that
stinkville no the thing
zone the smell this thing built and
between your ass on your nutsack there's
the bog of eternal stench and it's - it
stays with you and sometimes you're
watching TV at night and you're like man
hello it's done and you scratch and
what's going on down in that village
it's like on me and that's a little bit
and it's like a little piece of meat and
if you go to south you'll scratch like
top of your [ __ ] like a little bit
take that with your fingers now if it
smells like different like war so I get
the loofah that's what I did was how
convenient I am I'm a fat dude so I've
never I grew up in East Coast and ahead
of Hugh Middle East I learned how to
bathe so I take a loaf I pick up my nuts
and I loof underneath I move for the
dead skin and then what you do is I cut
a little loofah oh can I take that one
when I learn how to wrap it on my finger
I put like two inches in my [ __ ] and
clean the [ __ ] you know cuz they get
barnacles you get barnacles in cloud you
clean around like I don't stick my
finger in my ass I luckily you know that
way like this like yeah it's like how
you express anal glands right I like
this yeah you figured out I wash it but
you know there's these in the Korean
spas have these like gloves that are
loofah gloves okay that you can go in
and do whatever you got to do in the
crevices you can get them for 20 cents
on Amazon you've met 50 at once it's a
glove that's all loofah and you can just
get everything you don't have to be
doing arts and crafts with your loofah
know how do you change the finger one
cut it like every three weeks okay I
know but I think yeah I think maybe is
that I don't understand how the day's
work oh I don't know you bought this
[ __ ] house in 2000 where other day is
beyond me but I don't understand what
it's washing your [ __ ] or your balls
just tomorrow call the Lama I I don't
even know
where are you supposed to sit on it yeah
but doesn't I've tried it before and it
went everywhere right because you have
to learn how I felt like a squirter for
the first time you turn on the hot first
then you turn but you have to have a
towel yeah why don't you see in the
shower don't like them because maybe
you're on a move maybe you ever come
home with a guy and you're swapping spit
things account again hi oh we will baby
wipes please baby baby once I taste baby
wipe oh yeah in fact I could tell you
baby boy I knew a girl in college who
used to put chapstick cherry chapstick
on a movie that's brilliant yeah let's
go on let's make them give me a little
more face book it's like what uh so what
you do is you you go in the bathroom you
turn it on you sit you take the sweat
off your ass then you get a towel then
you can pull like that summer's eve
vaginal scrub and you just get a man
clean wait on mine or yours I wash my
balls of some of these roses rub
summer's eve and scrub will shine you
nuts like I wish I was trying to be
funny I used to date a girl she had it
was so the best thing is just
antibacterial so what I use it cleans
everything your advertisers no fishy no
do they spawn I haven't bought it I
haven't bought summer's eve as a man
since I got married because I don't want
my wife at me it does feel if I saw it
but if I saw summer's eve it a guy's
house vaginal scrub the best does it
have a little scratch or seeds and you
were the old one this is 95 there was a
girl I'm not planting seeds in my I used
to date don't Sunday night she had a
boyfriend she was happily in love well
on Sunday morning she would break up
with him every weekend okay and her and
I would go on a date we play hook the
roofie who first and we would go out
that crowded roofie huh she tried to
rule this is tremendous tremendous she
was good she was a real woman she just
was down where it happened to her you
stay in touch with exes yes
she's just getting separated because she
caught him having an affair with the
waitress at their restaurant no no she
was with him I loved her she was like
one of my best friends Oh call it that
we went out we did a couple lines of
coke I noticed your body was banging
I ate a [ __ ] and then we stayed friends
and I never said none of nobody like I
didn't say nothing
yeah and then one night we went out we
went up to parents house I was trying
her father grew weed in that town that's
really busy so he invited me to the
house she was there with a boyfriend
the boy was acting like an [ __ ] if
he's then getting home and she's like
what are you doing I don't know maybe
get a gram of coke she said you mind if
I come with you and then she goes and we
take it right up to the bus stop the bus
stop was a strip club oh [ __ ] face them
in not we below wait there is a strip
club there's a strip club called the bus
stop what stop that is hands down the
saddest name I've ever heard that was
run by like gangsters when the guy died
he left it to the church
so the church really owns the bus stop
at least they didn't I see [ __ ]
anything there was a little factory
behind the back was garlic with a
missing I got you roofies direct I don't
know what a real [ __ ] rapper is that
is it no hit naw naw it's a pill and
people supposedly break them in half and
put them in drinks put them in your
drink okay all right now how much
soldiers we get a gram of oil and then
she take house and I take mine did we go
why would you want to do blow and is
that an upper hand downer you do the
blow when I get you all [ __ ] psyched
up but then you get dead dick so you
take up the roofie
to calm it down a little bit get us by
agra back in the day thing that yeah 95
maybe but I've never taken my really I
would not you don't need it you're just
[ __ ] - you know what does balls know
I'm scared of what what it would do
tomorrow cuz it takes the blood away
from everything
no one needs to [ __ ] for four hours
maybe you do I don't know no four hours
wiped long times [ __ ] outta here
it's time for that yeast infection
waiting to happen
no I would
you uh I would [ __ ] I would never
take them I heard that there was gay men
in Hollywood that would take viagra and
ecstasy and you put it into a liquid
form they smell the turkey baster and
you pull it up your ass that's Rogan on
Tuesday really yeah
after I got the piranha thing this is 95
97 98 there was a gay ecstasy viagra up
your at well anything you put up your
[ __ ] is gonna go in your bun choice
yes
faster faster like a lot of people I
know used to do coke in there yeah with
a finger with a loofah listen you get
[ __ ] oh Jesus what's the difference
between the feeling of going up your
nose and going up your ass I never put
it up my ass oh you never did it once
no I would have if anything I would have
somebody blow it in me with a straw like
a Chinese chick that good with straws
you're saying too bad talk about the
Dolphins get that strong blowing up my
ass like this can be an eco-friendly
papers tragically no no they would melt
it was dissolved but what if you have
[ __ ] in your butt sorry no you take a
little bit you put the finger in there
then you put this drawn Chinese
Steinbeck coke right up their [ __ ] ass
it's all low but the shot where you
think you're dealing with joy bananas
you're always so a cocaine plus and you
do the cocaine to get amped up and then
you do the roofie to get your dick
functioning yes huh when you forget all
the stuff you did don't roofies make you
sleepy though yeah that maybe not with
the coke that rigor mortis no not with
the coke that's sleepy day not with the
scope and then so with the coke that we
get it's like doing a quaalude I never -
you are quaaludes amazing tremendous
tremendous just gave the last one I had
to Jordan Belfort the wolf of Wall
Street came on the show last week what I
it's a pills I bill and have quaaludes
gone like out of style what's the is
granty Canton the new version I listen
you know all you hear about is the
opiate problem
the only problem the or kind of problem
we've had a problem with those sorry
whether it was to malls or quaaludes or
valium or xaniix its percocet what's
happened that I had a conversation one
of my dear friends because my dear
friends has this child that struggles
with an opioid addiction and he said I
don't know what to do what I'm gonna how
we say you know what you've been a
[ __ ] hypocrite for starters they
ain't no cokes you don't understand we
were doing coke big [ __ ] little coke
heroin pills but it's true
you know these pills are leaving these
kids the Harold cheaper and it's cheaper
that's obsession right this waste with
fentanyl unbelievable you know what man
I take the leaves I drink to expressos
and I smoked a joint I'm good well did
you say if you were like okay I did I
you're gonna die in 20 minutes what's
the drug you do I eat a piece of
cheesecake I get a New York egg cream I
smoke this cigarette like a [ __ ]
animal I would smoke a cigarette like if
I got that old like I would get more
enjoyment of one set what Marlboro with
a real red sex life really I mean I knew
that
yeah I knew at the age of 12 that
marijuana did something to me if
somebody sat across he and said she had
a DD and a bunch of stuff and since she
started smoking pot she's got it
together I think I decided the same
thing one yeah I always had like little
self esteem when I always had all these
things my father dying yeah once I found
pot I found the hole hmm let me down it
takes away the background noise for me I
do at night before I go to bed I had to
take it easy cuz I was not the vapes I
can never quite tell how much I'm doing
and I tried a couple different brands
and now I just do like three or four
hits before I go to bed I was doing more
during Roseanne because I was stressed
out for obvious [ __ ] reasons and I
was starting to forget [ __ ] and I didn't
I didn't feel like I was quick so for me
like four hits before I go to bed it's
like the perfect amount where I can
still be like quick and optimal did you
ever do drugs following that you know I
didn't really
I did like I tried everything except
heroin I never did great with quaaludes
but I was never a I was always addicted
to dramatic situations and bad
relationships and not drugs I was did I
was addicted to drug addicts not alcohol
alcohol never did grow up in an
alcoholic home and I was always the one
poor in the alcohol so I became the
people pleaser I just never I never got
a taste for it you ever have a drink I
mean I do sometimes I can't wine gives
me [ __ ] migraine I can't
so I read my thing is not worth it you
know something like ice is [ __ ] fun
but then tomorrow night I'm always doing
stand-up at night so I'm always just
like haven't but tequila is what I can
do and not get a headache the next day
he's out his by the team I did
guys I'm I did a lot of bad things but
it's so weird how my mind works when I
was 17 years old I saw a car accident 17
I saw car accident I drove up on it
being a friend of mine I had acid
horrible experience and I heard the
elves and I heard the screams they had
to get the jaws of life to cut you know
all that [ __ ] I'll never forget either
the guy said son when I got took out a
bottle and he goes there with drinking
and that stayed with me like I have a
statement hope it doesn't offend anybody
it's 2019 if you get a DUI just [ __ ]
kill yourself because you're that
[ __ ] stupid yeah and selfish I am
just like a kid in New York about this
thing in New York yesterday two days ago
guy well an eight-hour shift and forgot
it's two one year old twins were in the
car now how do you forget for eight
hours that you know me my way and I'm
like what to a point now where we know
not to leave anything in the [ __ ] car
just don't leave anything in the car yes
your dog your cat check not even for a
minute
nothing bothers me more than when I go
lead do you wanna ride what Whitney ago
joke do you wanna ride yeah and Lawson
you go click click with your [ __ ] car
yeah I open your car and you want to put
a suitcase in the back of the trunk do
me a favor stop this [ __ ]
I started and then do whatever the [ __ ]
you want get the air in here for that
minute I'm sitting like those [ __ ]
like those twins I'm sitting there
waiting to [ __ ] die because you want
to put that in your mother cause we're
here get the [ __ ] car got the goddamn
AC and then you can do whatever the [ __ ]
you want you can walk talk as well as I
got the AC on I've been with people who
have said I'm gonna go inside for a
minute and they've turned off the column
way what are you doing the reason I have
the car I have is because I could turn
my AC on while I'm walking to the car
it's on the Frey get in there [ __ ]
crazy heart
then people putting me in their car then
going hold on I gotta take some mother
thanks what the [ __ ] so we all know that
that like all that type of [ __ ] like if
you got a DUI did they give him a blood
test and he had been drinking the guy
that left it there's gotta be a by the
way he was doing an eight-hour shift so
when you're telling me I don't know so
what you're telling me isn't that eight
hours you didn't talk to you ex-wife or
your wife your wife didn't call you and
say how the babies are doing cuz I know
when I'm on the road I talk to my wife
every two hours how's mercy doing what's
going on and she like universal did the
kid pick up and she smack him back I'm
checking so for eight hours something I
had a person when they walked out he
either was doing drugs for eight hours
passed out something was wrong and I
feel the same way about duis I'm sorry
if you're an out here your recovery I'm
not here to hurt nobody's feelings but
in today's day and a they can I'm like
dad one of the most powerful things I
heard when I was going to a meetings
when I was in al-anon but I was going to
open a a meetings you know helps you
understand the disease and this woman
was sharing and she was like everyone
out driving tonight is safer because I'm
in here hundreds of people are safer cuz
I'm here it's like it just blew my mind
just thinking about it she's like I just
didn't want to kill anybody
I like up do coke and drive I'm Mario
Andretti you gotta seem that he's do
coke when I would do Langley down found
on the Thursday night I could smoke a
joint and I won't smoke in the car yeah
very seldom do I smoke when I'm driving
yeah I'll smoke when we get to our
destination I smoked before I leave the
house I think they give us a great deal
if I let you
spoken yeah [ __ ] cartoons anyway yeah
yeah I will get in green so leave the
pot at home you smoke you go for a car
ride but to do you I like that I cannot
even sip I was like maybe I should get
Janet on it mm-hmm what an extra line
with this [ __ ] mmm like my fear cuz I
fall apart if a cop pulls me over and I
have on my breath I will fall apart I
can murder somebody you can question me
yeah I love Joe cool yeah yeah but when
it comes to alcohol I I start stuttering
really oh my god it's that cuz your
tolerance is low I just know the fear I
guess I'm getting pulled over with
alcohol because I don't have a ground to
stand on oh wow that's I've told people
for years I didn't have a license for
ten years I got pulled over every Friday
coming home from Irvine in Ontario cuz I
think doing 90 no license no California
life what did you do
come on teacher tell them the truth I
got lost on the plane I haven't got a
chance to get on my California license
they didn't smell out they have a rule
and that way on Fridays and Saturdays if
you're speeding with you're a gentleman
really if you don't know about wall
you're Brett 90% of times I'll let you
go especially have to talk o'clock is
that LAPD or is that all of all of it
they don't mind they'll be talking about
that's so true well they had background
check yeah they do the background check
then we get pulled over together me you
are again how cool was it yeah I love
our problem never ever ever because
we're without alcohol on your breath on
a Friday and sadly you don't have a leg
to stand on because even if we go to the
comic store witnesses at 8:30
hey Joey have a tequila with me my show
got picked up bull and I do the eight
dirty show when I do Jove ten o'clock
show when I get in the car 12 if I get
pulled over he's gonna ask me a question
yeah yeah and then what if I tell him no
because it was four hours ago
and then I get out my trip wrong so as
soon as you tell the cop yes he's going
to take you out of the car
yeah so just don't
right and he won't take you out of the
[ __ ] you don't know how people drink
and do stand-up Ella blows my mind that
somebody comments do it I could smoke
pot not right away and do stand-up the
coke I learned my first year that's not
gonna work cocaine the night before so
many comics did so much I mean we're
like the first generation of comics that
aren't doing cocaine right well the
first generation of comics that really
aren't doing anything that's why if you
have a problem today in the comedy world
making a drug bomb your careers not
gonna last because there's so many good
comics that's right that aren't cause
they're drinking Jamba Juice and doing
yoga for 20 years ago Mitch was on the
road causing problems
George Lopez is on the road causes Louis
what was miss like Mitch was a
sweetheart
Mitch was just was his comedy at the
time alternative comet-like did he feel
like could he go onstage after anybody
do you mean like today that would be
considered like alternative comedy don't
you think he was alternative well he was
on a different level
his writing mm-hmm charisma started to
do turn around and have to comedy and
follow he was just doing was he as a
person was he fun we used to play tennis
every day what I'd 98 me him Stanhope
will go to Gorky Park on Vista and for
fountain that's a park there there used
to be a Russian park and they used to
sell drugs there but me
Stanhope nicked Apollo oh yeah cuz
nicked Apollo and Mitch Hedberg lived in
the same building on Shira Bonita in
Sunset oh yeah that's a famous building
so you had what wolf was on Vista mm-hmm
then you have el compadre and Ralphie
may was on Schrader and then you had
Shara bonito mm-hmm you had Mitch and
Nick shoot you couldn't be two more
dissimilar accounted there were
neighbors so whenever Mitch Hedberg will
play the guitar nikto [ __ ] hated
Mitch like he would torture Mitch could
not be more different
and then her son had Doug Stanhope which
he still has that apartment huh he kept
that apartment after all these years
because it's rent control that's why he
will not leave that place I went over
the updates still there honey
so all those guys used to get together
we drink iced tea and that 3:30 we'd go
to Gorky Park and I still remember like
he was killing Mitch Hedberg was already
killing at the improv it was a big
improv guy Laugh Factory I kinda
remember him at the store but I still
remember him and I having a conversation
about him all in New York let me tell
them I think it was a good idea because
there's nobody else like of that huh
every New York talks to the audience and
you know how with Steven Wright still
performing it like wasn't the closest
thing he was stylistically right to
Steven right Steven Wright was
performing but Mitch was just [ __ ] was
just like a swagger about you know all
that [ __ ] you know you have been walking
down the street my guy gives you a sign
he's really saying hey you drove us away
from me
yeah he was just you know the thing
about going to the restaurant mr. and
mrs. Smith yeah you clever a [ __ ] he was
like a year a to roll then he got the
big deal yeah and this is something this
is how big the deal was like when they
sign Mitch in Montreal on paper it's
supposed to be the biggest deal ever
given by now they probably broke his
interest was the interest was so high
I'm Mitch
that they closed the Improv on Monday
Tuesday and Wednesday just to showcase
to people are to know industry people
well so everybody came back to tell
their perspectives that the Mitch
Hedberg train was open it was trying to
write their check hmm
so Monday was show running soon as there
was writers and Wednesday was the
network she took out a [ __ ] kid I
swear to god that's how powerful he was
they do not do [ __ ] like that and Fox
gave me the deal they started working
him into the 70s show all right there's
been Chris all that they were doing it
right
they were doing this one they were doing
right they won't work in a minute you do
like a sitcom yes
Fox they were doing it right because
they take Whitney Whitney's never done a
school play then she goes to read the
pilot oh yeah the next thing you know
you're playing your sister and your
buddy and that's right that's right you
know and then you get recast yeah so you
know there's just so many things that
Wow but then he moved to New York and
that's what he was really that's what
you really think of doing all those
spots yeah yeah katal words and all
those places were starting Hills now I
wish it was 98 maybe Saturday and that's
what Comedy Central was doing like yes
there were the special premium blends
yes
Comedy Central really had the spec
Comedy Central Presents were it was
almost like The Tonight Show if you did
one you were just huge and then I guess
the drugs got a whole menu for a couple
years you just heard stories you know
but I was in my old drug war mm-hmm you
know Pablo Francisco I dearly loved he
was causing havoc when you're on the
road no one can say anything I stole
them [ __ ] George Lopez falling off a
stool in Miami and they couldn't do
rainy on Thursday and Friday you know
everybody was pretty much they stacked
remember towel in 99 in Miami at The
Improv opening up the audience they
bring you drunk like I mean that's I
remember talking some comics struggling
god I just got sober but people send me
shots and the club owners give you drug
you know I mean it just seems like it
was probably even harder back then it
was probably hard for a lot of people
you know let's be honest I went on the
road to do drugs
mmm-hmm I didn't go on the road did do
copy tommy was just how I was gonna make
money because it just felt like you
didn't have any accountability
yeah no radio no nothing after I do that
20 minutes I sit by the bathroom yeah
and I just wait for the pigeons to come
out one by one
we loved you you did what's the story
let's do a bump I came with my boyfriend
so we'll get to Jack let's get the [ __ ]
out me and next thing you know I'm gone
yeah there's no responsibility that was
I wasn't I wasn't too smart and getting
high comedy was 30 percent of that
journey ever it's so weird I don't think
I know anyone that does cocaine no weird
like I don't know any of them like not
that I would call them out right now on
your show but I don't know anyone who's
the stand-up that really does cocaine
and it's up I'm sure they're out there I
don't see it you know either
I don't see it I don't I don't see
everyone's juicing and everyone's
[ __ ] key toad paleo everyone let's
work it out with Rogan you know you and
I both know that be a successful stand
on line to do what you want to do on the
road and those show speeders in the
traveling and you know if you landed our
sample and you're not in shape you're
gonna die well also we're in this new
thing now where people see you and they
take pictures of you all the time and
there's no I get to behave a different
way after the show or in the air before
it's everything's gonna be very care you
know who gave me amazing advice actually
when I first started stand-up Andrew
Dice Clay was at The Comedy Store and
I'm such a young idiot I was like 25
when I was like I'm done maybe like
couple months of stand up but I was
excuse me but what's the jib like some
advice for me and he was like sleep
eight hours a night I said it's true
just sleep you have to take so much care
of yourself you could take care of the
people that pay to come and see you go
check you know saving money all year I
got a whole mess of always I look at you
with the nice white shirt on my way you
can't sell a ten thousand dollar truck
with a ten dollar presentation do you
think I dress too sloppy what stage
you're making me think I should dress
someone no I think you dress very
womanly
oh really yeah I don't want to see your
tits when I'm up there yeah I want you
to cover them because why gather
distraction
yeah I really like nice hoodies but I
sometimes I feel like am i a little
sloppy you told me something once it
stayed with me a long time and you got a
lot of respect
you said that when you came to this town
you had two choices you can either suck
dick or want to be one of the guys and
you put your hand up in a ponytail and
you look this up as other swimming as
you could and that goes a long way you
know I've seen girls that there was a
girl at the Comedy Store then annotate
you know she was into old guys like she
was like no name she was like 28 hot but
her boyfriends oh like sixty yeah any
times they [ __ ] her once a week and
they got and one guy gave her a set of
tits
she's the comical Richard she done it
Oh what do you know she's a very funny
would always show up once a week and
there was a beautiful [ __ ] Porsche
[ __ ] this oh yeah she was she was 24
hot to trot So Cal I mean but the
weather did that they did the tip
transfer in Mexico transfer whatever the
[ __ ] they implant implant they didn't
Mexico didn't know what to do with this
vein wait what is this true this is a
true story
what vein I don't know women have a vein
that goes I am big [ __ ] there's no vein
problem she had a vein that some reason
the silicone pushed that yeah so the
vein came right it was like you were
doing comedy with almost watch basis
she's got too many dicks that phased so
this was here the cleavage and this vein
came from here all the way down like a
[ __ ] like a bodybuilders arm when you
look at a bodybuilder how their vein
look yeah yeah so she went on stage with
cleavage and everybody would come out
and go Jesus Christ that vein on at it
you know sure because that's all they
see is the vein annotate cover that
[ __ ] thing I don't know but I don't I
don't understand no I'm sorry maybe she
didn't transfer maybe she got a cheap
maybe she had a cheap daddy and he sent
to the Mexico your tits done and
mini-malls you gotta get you gotta go to
the rear I'll do a chick they got if
that's not an I swear to god one was up
here yeah you gotta be careful guy that
used with a little chemical thing in
there you know you used it you know what
the key to good fake Texas what is that
they
when you go out on anesthesia they hang
you basically on a crucifix and do it
while you're standing up yeah so that
they fall right so most of the time they
have you on a bed and they do it and
then your little [ __ ] - alligator
eyes you know but the good surgeons put
you up on the wall and do it while
you're standing up but that's the ones
that fall well because most people have
them but the good ones don't seem fake
you know and also under the muscle is
the key although we've come over the
muscle just looks like Joey's nut sex
how was it preparing busily next better
you coming on down you thought you saw
me a lot I feel like preparing a few
times at Sycamore flappers a bunch
Sycamore I like that place it's weird I
feel like and tell me if I'm crazy or if
this is normal like I feel like the more
people know me as a stand-up the scared
or I am in a way to disappoint so I feel
like I can't do a [ __ ] at you know I
have to do a [ __ ] of the Comedy Store
improv places like that so this round I
really started going to like little [ __ ]
holes I went to flappers I went to bars
like I kind of ass like you know the
more success I get as a stand-up the
shittier venues I'm going to because I
want to be able to just try out new [ __ ]
and [ __ ] around and not like if I'm
following you were wrong and I don't
feel like I can try out new [ __ ] you
know like I want to deliver because I
mean you know following this guy's
[ __ ] nightmare it's like like riding
an earthquake so I I it was it was fun
but also a lot of work and the stuff
that I was talking about like I was
scared this is the first time I've ever
pro special I was like scared like what
if the PC police get me what if I get
cancelled am I allowed and that's what I
called the special can I touch it for a
lot of reasons but I was a little
worried I wasn't gonna say the right
term or get back flash in the comments I
was like I gotta [ __ ] shake that [ __ ]
off this is I think just because of
what's going on and all this I'm gonna
pull up a tweet that you sent eight
years ago and now you're homophobic I
you know I was scared which was a poor
my tweets time in year
we have really have to stop living yeah
you're a very decent girl you know it's
not why you took your deck on the
shoulder for sunrise no I knew you know
your Sargento who you're marching but in
the meantime you're raping us epic rant
yeah yeah yeah you know what if you said
something 20 years ago I said it no God
knows oh my state of mind away so you
take it seriously you want to that's
like that I used to do the Royal shame
on you we used to do the most sexist
racist offensive [ __ ] ever you know but
I think I just I definitely I think the
biggest part of this special is I wanted
to make sure that it didn't just work in
New York and LA because we get a little
myopic now so I did 43 cities everywhere
in between New York and LA a lot of us
go San Francisco New York LA got it let
me tape it it's like that doesn't
represent everybody that's good so I
definitely especially talking about the
stuff that's in the news like I talk a
lot about the sexual harassment stuff
and I'm so glad you know that I did is
big of a tour as I did is I was sick and
it was hard but you know I was talking
about the me to stuff and sexual
harassment and I was like so does me to
made it to Houston I pretty sure was
Houston and this you know I was talking
about like when your ass gets grabbed at
work you know and this woman just yelled
out take the compliment and move on like
thank you it's true there's different
points of view about this not right not
wrong I can't judge but I want to make
sure that the special doesn't feel like
you know I don't know I want to peel to
everybody and I don't want you prepare
for this year and a half okay so 18
months about but I did I was doing two
shows a night the flappers then I go to
the Comedy Store and then I was doing
six shows a weekend see I've changed my
whole outlook I'm just doing the store
really yeah in LA where were you doing
for you would do hi cap everything I
just have to really Netflix special I
saw so many holes in my game
interesting that's it if they don't like
the a material don't ya know get softer
mm-hmm
I know I have I've been doing this for
20 years I'll come up with your theme
but yeah enough we going down and
worrying about who you follow but it
used to be a commie story you go on and
[ __ ] around there is ten people ten
Germans in the audience that got a
Groupon now it's every I come off stage
it's every person that runs a [ __ ]
network it's that's the way everyone's
filming it's like look they just want
you to beat him yourself you always been
use eight minutes of material yeah and
substitute some material in there so you
don't look I had to stop going to the
other place
yeah because even if I kill the flappers
on the drive home why did that count I'm
a bully
yeah interesting come over there with a
bunch I know there's a poor girl over
there that's been doing comedy but yeah
so she never she has to follow me like
you know who you are I mean and everyone
who's listening is a fan of yours and
you know you are what I would say the
heart one of the hardest comments to
follow right now yes I told you about
the time that I had to follow you and I
started stretching in the hallway for
Netflix yeah I was I started doing like
oh and it's the first time I ever was
like hey do you want to know next I just
you can't like I was trying to get
someone else to go if I can get the
energy
no I'll I always either the Netflix
special I always want to act I always
want to feel the way I feel before I go
up at the store mm-hmm I always want to
feel that panic do you feel panic before
you go on at the store oh my god do you
get that from him he told me about it I
wouldn't surprise guests it but yeah
he's told me three years ago minute oh
yeah I wouldn't think you were capable
of that I was there think about being
there with Mitch he was that I had to
showcase for Bitsey twice when she was
the only person in the room when you
would have when she would walk back and
forth no didn't do a spot you got in
your car you like this might be my last
night at the store like I lived through
that wait like showcasing for her just
don't be like her being the other side
and you got an 11 o'clock spot when you
walk in she's in the booth sitting with
with Eleanor and Andrew and Paul
Rodriguez and she's like hi honey will
here to watch you in your okay they
don't want to main Roman Dom or Evers
and funny laugh sobbing [ __ ] and you're
like no so you thought you stretch that
and I think of my job now you go up
there so I would I would always be
honest with her if I saw him one day I
would always tell her I did great in the
original I ate a bag of dicks available
I always eat X another shoe ago that's
fine
what is that I the main room I oh I
prefer the original room to the main
room is that all do we all is that your
okay
I just another time the more you do
these stupid Sam Tripoli shows Roman
shows right nothing nothing stupid
nobody it's getting your people mellow
Tomic every time they do a show and they
call you do it because you're going down
anyway you might as well jump on their
show yeah and you'll see you'll do the
sob that it's either or yeah either
destroy such a high in the door and then
you have nine dicks down your throat in
two minutes in and the [ __ ] main room
20 seconds ago just 20 [ __ ] [ __ ] this
up and now they just stabbed me down
like I know it's crazy
where did you tape the set DC Sidney
Harman hall shows it I did two shows but
we did I learned this the hard way cuz
the first show is always a camera
rehearsal so I did a practice show on
Friday it was just four cameras to see
what I was I move around a lot and the
cameras they got at the camera people
got to know how to follow me and and
then I did two
taped shows on Saturday and I used
mostly from the second show Saturday
it comes out Tuesday comes out Tuesday
yeah July 30th midnight yep I'm so happy
but it's it's a it's nuts like for me
like I have some crazy [ __ ] happen at
the end of the show
because I said you know I think I have a
robot in it I don't know if I've seen
that part of it there's a robot in the
show it was just insane cuz I kind of
just was like okay so my fourth special
I want it to be super memorable there's
so much so many great specials now so
many great comics like I just want to do
something really memorable so it's kind
of a crazy experiment at the end that'll
make you feel weird now you've done a
comedy specials for who - for Comedy
Central one for HBO this one's for
Netflix how was the heo I saw the I love
the HBO thank you you said something to
me where you said that you appreciated I
just I [ __ ] around with the crowd just
cuz they really liked that I just feel
like it I think what is tricky about
specials as you do every single night
you get to do something different and
then you're like I got a pic at 8:00
like I just if it feels right I just do
it and it's taping even though it [ __ ]
up the continuity it feels weird to not
trust your gut while performing I don't
want it to ever feel rehearsed so I had
[ __ ] around with some in the audience
and I just like it leave it I love this
that's what happened she's got balls
that's what happened what am I not gonna
just another show I try to treat it like
just another show and what am i sent it
was uh it was good I'm proud of it it's
it's gonna get me in some trouble
you know I say that some feminists or
[ __ ] people are gonna be mad at me
but that's what comedy is like I just I
can't we're not here to take care of
your feelings we're here to make you
laugh and make you sink and the
self-righteous indignation shit's gotten
a little much crazy it's gotten crazy
I'm gonna piss some people off and maybe
that's okay I just read all the change
in [ __ ] Halloween my at the Saturday
because too many people complaining that
no one Halloween to fall on a Wednesday
so they want to change it to Sally the
same [ __ ] to change Columbus Day
Columbus [ __ ] alone but they had to
make them biggie was they canceled
Columbia and what do you call it you
don't it's gone and did you and did you
this people day columbus killed a bunch
of [ __ ] people
[ __ ] with 2,000 years ago do that
well I knew once they change Columbus
Day then they'd wanted to go yes they're
coming for you wait you never see one
Luther King's neck yeah [ __ ] Nazi day
they do everything yep we can't
celebrate Nazi day anymore no ah damn I
love you I love you son regulations
thank you for taking the time it's just
busy schedule anything for you there you
got all these shows on tap you see I
retweeted everything thank you they find
you beside that Instagram what are we
doing Whitney done I don't do the tic
TOCs I don't do the snapchats I do
Instagram and Twitter 36 years old what
about the website Whitney Cummings calm
that's it sure don't put no prominent I
love you look gorgeous as usual
oh gosh the best cheekbones in the
business I really people think they're
fake I love best balls in the business
between us [ __ ] unstoppable yours I
would do a team of I love you anything
July 30th Netflix streaming my special
that's it a book dates in a couple
months take your time but hurry up
[ __ ] is no longer the Lincoln
Theater next Friday theater in the world
yeah man whatever but that's old that
but DC you got tons of tickets left all
right I want to thank my beautiful
Whitney Cummings I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] for
always having our back don't forget
about me there right don't forget that
I'm gonna put Joey Joey in the beginning
of the show some is here uncle Joey's
here you gotta be a gentleman you got to
clean your bumper before she sucks the
[ __ ] help tailpipe
it's summer guys it's time to trim the
[ __ ] weeds and let the [ __ ] tree
stand tall like a [ __ ] Savage you've
got your [ __ ] dick looks like the
Addams Family you don't need that my
friends over at manscaped created the
only tool you need to shave your nutsack
and to keep the area around the [ __ ]
pogo stick a life nice and fluff in trim
it's called a lot more 2.0 for a reason
you know why they threw away 21.0 no
more [ __ ] Momo's in the back it means
it won't Nick or yes or snag your
nutsack plus its
perfect for travel it's easy to charge
you can manscape when you're on the road
when you're on business when you're
playing golf just in case you bump into
a blow job on the [ __ ] golf course
you never know you're made in a hole of
nine and there's always some [ __ ]
little fan there diners suck some golf
ball dick anyway you could do it one
hand and I don't care if you lost your
arm like the drummer from Def Leppard
nuts it'd still be shaving manscape will
get your [ __ ] [ __ ] and nutsack
looking shiny and smooth and if this is
the first time you consider manscaping
they got the deal for you grab a pen
it's called the perfect package comes
with the lawnmower and a safety razor
plus the crop preserver especially
formulated deodorant so your balls don't
stink like a [ __ ] giraffes [ __ ]
and they got the Reviver a spritz that
tones and refreshes the [ __ ] dick and
the balls to keep it cool right now
especially during the humid time you
know I'm saying with the perfect package
your pouch will be powdered and your
pole will be [ __ ] beautiful mwah as
they say in Europe qu'est-ce que c'est
listen the church family gets 20% off
your first order when you use promo code
Church CH you are CH at manscape com
listen for the cheap seats and if you
order the perfect package don't throw in
the free travel bag the same when I got
it's [ __ ] beautiful leathers got a
few compartments in there when you use
promo code Church you got a free travel
bag all right that's manscape dot-com
use promo code church for 20% off your
first order and keep your balls [ __ ]
clean the church is also brought to you
by CBD lion calm you understand me
CBD lion listen everybody wants to be
captain [ __ ] CBD but no more all
right this is the way to go
CBD lion calm aren't you lucky uncle
Joey [ __ ] found it for you
they make CBD products from start to
finish
whether you want a vain cartridge you
want a shatter
they got you covered and if you're not
into smoke and listen they got dummies
orange ones and the raspberry ones that
will put you in a different [ __ ]
planet or do the tensions like uncle
Joey right under your tongue an hour
before you go to bed their products
[ __ ] clean Bobby and then not like
the [ __ ] fake things you see a liquor
store and foot massage places and all
that [ __ ]
CBD Lyon is the real deal you don't
believe me go to CBD line comm and check
out that third-party lab results
yourself listen the church family gets
20% off I check out all right 20% off at
checkout when you press in Church CH you
are CH that CBD Lyon dot-com slash
Church at checkout
I want to thank manscaped I want to
thank CBD line comm and I want to thank
you little [ __ ] for always
being there for me
don't forget the night of August the
Lincoln Theater in DC we still got a few
tickets available to Borgata sold out
and then the [ __ ] Friday the 13th in
September I'm at the Majestic Theatre in
Dallas smelling like gunpowder like the
Kennedys tickets are left and then the
next night I'm at San Antonio Texas
Texas at the Aztec Peter I love you
[ __ ] have a great week it's
Monday grab your [ __ ] dick and go out
there knock door the door you know I'm
saying tell him uncle Joey sent you
she's Whitney coming is the Christ
killer I love you check this [ __ ]
music